this was a roller coaster at least for
me personally like I thought I had this
show figured out and then each time of
each episode ended I was like oh my gosh
what was it like James I know you're an
EP on this but did when reading the
scripts did you have any idea what was
coming next
no I
just sent me the script it was 2019
we'd met maybe sort of six five six
months before that socially and hung out
quite a bit and then this script arrived
in my inbox and I basically had the
experience that you just explained which
was I
I read
five pages and thought okay I know what
this is and then five pages later it's
like oh no silly me it's not that it's
absolutely this and 15 pages Pages later
was like well I don't know what this is
but I I but I love it and I cannot
believe that I'm gonna get to be in it
and the answer is yes cheers to all of
the questions the answers yes and I'm so
proud of the the reaction that we're
getting from from people who've watched
it it's it's really thrilling for us
it's been such a journey you know
absolutely and Jazz I imagine like as
the writer it's probably so much fun to
sort of take audiences on it for you
like what was like do you enjoy writing
this where you kind of have the audience
and second guessing it's hugely fun and
I'm I'm using here every trick in the
book you know anything I can think of
that I feel I can do drama wise I'm I'm
I'm laying it all out here in in an
order that that makes the story sing
James Channel he read the first episode
and and agreed to do it and challenged
me to make each episode better than the
last
uh which is a great thing to be you know
just quite simply to look at it and go
well was that more fun than the last one
yeah uh um and I kind of feel like we
did it like like it it it feels like
that that um
that my favorite one's the last one you
know so so uh you know I really feel the
the that challenge really kept me honest
it kept me on my toes uh and it meant
that I wasn't allowed to let it wander
you know there was one point in the
middle of this where where I had
uh I'd written an episode four and
episode five this is just to talk about
producing for a moment and James was
like I think that's one episode you know
I think that's 25 minutes of material
rather than 50 minutes and which wasn't
sure enough sure enough it it was it
became so and as such it kept it on that
kind of vertiginous keep coming at you
like you're drinking from a fire hose
pace which I think is quite addictive
no abs and I feel like it's a show where
like I had a couple days to watch it and
I thought oh I'll watch some episodes
today and then some episodes the next
day and then I just ended up sitting
there watching the whole thing because I
was like now I have to see what happened
you know
um I also have to ask about Tom Jones I
mean yes obviously Legend icon whose
idea was to bring it on was it always
going to be Tom Jones yes it was always
Tom Jones I mean the the the subjects of
the drama for start Tom Jones is an
absolute Legend icon we should all be so
lucky first of all second of all you
know Tom Jones is a personal story and
he does play a character called Tom
Johnson so I think this is it starts
applying is it his personal story is
that he is a man who was married to the
same woman for many many decades but had
10 000 lovers uh and so he kind of spans
the the two options that we have
available before us in uh life as in
mammals which is you know is it one or
is it lots
and James what was it like working with
them oh it was amazing it was incredible
like it's you know just in episode one I
think Jess's stage Direction says that
my character is called Jamie and it says
Jamie looks and he sees Tom Jones the
actual Tom Jones and so you're from that
minute you really are thinking well what
do we do if Tom Jones
doesn't want to do it who who how do you
he's Irreplaceable who is that person
and luckily he said yes and I will say
you know what what an actor what a
performance like what he does he's so
natural he's so comfortable in his skin
I it was just it was a wonderful day and
everything came together that day the
weather the setting and Tom Jones
and Tom Jones yeah
um you know James I feel like you know
with this show and then lately each
other and dang you are heading into this
like new chapter
um at least to me is there something
you're looking forward to as you head
into this new chapter
I mean yeah I I sort of
I hope I'm moving into a new chapter my
reason for leaving the Late Late Show
really is
because I I want I can't shake this sort
of feeling inside me that I wonder if
there's another adventure out there I
wonder if there's one more thing to do
um and I didn't want to wake up and be
60 and think oh I missed a whole chunk
of parts that I could have played you
know so I'm excited to see what's next
I'm excited to see what's out there
um
we'd love to make more of this show I
feel like that's something which is is
possible if Jazz can find the story I
mean look if you enjoy the show if you
like the show it's really
it's like it's 70 Jazz and then the
other 30 is just split between the rest
of the cast and you can divvy that up
how you want really so
uh you know I I I'm shooting the show I
was really I felt so comfortable doing
it and I loved doing it so much and and
I'm so proud of it and that's an amazing
feeling when you do something that was
hard a challenge and at the end of it
you just feel really proud so I'm
excited to see what might be next year
yeah no I mean again like I said it's
one of those shows that I couldn't stop
watching it but I did have a thought
which and I want to know uh your take uh
both of you is do you think married
couples should watch the show together
I think that's a brilliant question
um
I really hope so
I think that it
will be thrilling and exciting and
challenging and tricky and possibly
who knows completely Redemptive yeah who
knows that you wouldn't watch this and
sit down and
confess something or sit down and ask a
question or sit down and say we've we've
been drifting you know I need to check
in we need to you know all of these
things could could could
occur I do think that the it will be
a thrilling ride in a game to play where
you suddenly start to to feel that
something that you're watching that
could never
implicate you
suddenly has you in its crosshairs